joyfulness is half your health
the beginning of health is sleep
good health is the sister of beauty
[Music]
if you want to live long and be healthy
drink like a dog and eat like a cat
[Music]
work is half of Health
he who doesn't have health has nothing
good health and good sense are two great
blessings
vention is better than cure
[Music]
a healthy Soul cannot live in a dry body
an imaginary ailment is worse than a
disease
a broken hand works but not a broken
heart
foreign
than a consumptive philosopher
[Music]
just because you're not sick doesn't
mean you're healthy
[Music]
the tiredness of the body is the health
of the Soul
[Music]
a good laugh and a long sleep are the
best cures in the doctor's book
[Music]
who takes medicine and neglects his diet
wastes the skill of his doctors
oh
health is better than wealth
[Music]
eat well drink in moderation and sleep
soundly in these three good health
abounds
the rich have medicine the poor have
health
he who has Health has hope he who has
hope has everything
[Music]
as the person who has health is Young so
the person who owes nothing is rich
sometimes the body becomes healthy by
being very sick
fresh air impoverishes the doctor
[Music]
good health is more important than
making a living
[Music]
limit your desires and you will improve
your health
no time for your health today will
result in no health for your time
tomorrow
[Music]
diseases of the Soul are more dangerous
than those of the body
[Music]
when the heart is at ease the body is
healthy
from the bitterness of disease man
learns the sweetness of Health
a man too busy to take care of his
health is like a mechanic too busy to
take care of his tools
[Music]
one who eats plain food is healthy
Health not gold or silver is true wealth
[Music]
good health is a crown on the head of a
well person that only a sick person can
see
[Music]
health is the greatest of human
blessings
[Music]
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
so many spend their health gaining their
wealth and then have to spend their
wealth to regain their health
[Music]
health is priceless wealth invest while
you can
[Music]
if you have health you probably will be
happy and if you have health and
happiness you have all the wealth you
need even if it is not all you want
health is like money we never have a
true idea of its value until we lose it
nothing looks as good as good health
feels
[Music]
I believe that the greatest gift you can
give your family and the world is a
healthy you
[Music]
happiness is the new Rich inner peace is
the new success health is the New Wealth
kindness is a new cool
health is the soul that animates all the
enjoyments of Life which fade and are
tasteless without it
healthy citizens are the greatest asset
a country can have
[Music]
to keep the body in good health is a
duty otherwise we shall not be able to
keep our minds strong and clear
take care of your body it is the only
place you have to live
eating healthy can cost you money eating
unhealthy can cost you your life
if you keep ignoring The Whispers from
your body eventually you'll be forced to
deal with its screams
your health is a focused investment of
time and energy it doesn't have to come
with crippling financial debt unless you
allow it
[Music]
health is adding a level of intention to
every area of your life
health is a daily practice not a 30-day
diet
[Music]
your health is your greatest gift never
take it for granted
the higher your energy level the more
efficient your body the better you feel
and the more you will use your talent to
produce outstanding results
[Music]
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you don't want drink what you
don't like and do what you'd rather not
physical fitness is not only one of the
most important keys to a healthy body it
is also the basis of dynamic and
creative intellectual activity
to get rich never risk your health for
health is wealth
when you ask people what affects their
well-being most they think of health and
wealth
when health is absent wisdom cannot
reveal itself art cannot become manifest
strength cannot be exerted wealth is
useless and reason is powerless
give a man health and a course to steer
and he'll never stop to trouble about
whether he's happy or not
let food be thy medicine and Medicine
thy food
[Music]
money is the most envied but the least
enjoyed health is the most enjoyed but
the least envied
[Music]
a land with lots of hearing can get
along with few doctors
[Music]
before healing others heal yourself
a man with a cough cannot conceal
himself
[Music]
sometimes the remedy is worse than a
disease
[Music]
the foundation of success in life is
good health that is the substrate of
Fortune it is also the basis of
Happiness a person cannot accumulate a
fortune very well when he is sick
good health is not something we can buy
but it can be an extremely valuable
savings account
be careful about reading Health books
you may die of a misprint
[Music]
ill health a body or mind is defeat
Health alone is Victory let all men if
they can manage it contrived to be
healthy
[Music]
ingredients of health and long life are
great Temperance open-air easy labor and
little care
a wise man should consider that health
is the greatest of human blessings and
learn how by his own thought to derive
benefit from his illnesses
if you don't do what's best for your
body you're the one who comes up on the
short end
health is the greatest of all
possessions a pale cobbler is better
than a sick King
[Music]
become a thoroughly good man is the best
prescription for keeping a sound mind
and a sound body
[Music]
the healthy and strong individual is the
one who asks for help when he needs it
whether he has an abscess on his knee or
on his soul
Eat to Live not live to eat
feed a cold and starve a fever
all the money in the world can't buy you
back good health
a fit healthy body that is the best
fashion statement
to ensure good health eat lightly
breathe deeply live moderately cultivate
cheerfulness and maintain an interest in
life
every day you do one of two things in
yourself build health or produce disease
[Music]
a healthy man is a successful man
if you need medical advice let these
three things be your Physicians a
cheerful mind relaxation for business
and a moderate diet
people who laugh actually live longer
than those who don't laugh
few people realize that Health fairies
according to the amount of laughter
[Music]
please
knowing that we can be loved exactly as
we are gives us all the best opportunity
for growing into the healthiest of
people
early to bed early to rise makes a man
healthy wealthy and wise
good humor is the health of the Soul
sadness is its poison
our bodies are our Gardens our Wills are
our gardeners
health is the thing that makes you feel
that now is the best time of year
[Music]
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments
foreign